now if you watched president biden's
inauguration yesterday
there were a few standout moments but
perhaps the one that
may stick in your mind was the inaugural
poet it's the youth poet laureate amanda
gorman who delivered that and at 22
she is the youngest person ever to
deliver
an inaugural poem a nation that
isn't broken but simply unfinished we
the successors of a country and the time
where a skinny black girl descended from
slaves
and raised by a single mother can dream
of becoming president only to find
herself reciting
for one well let's talk to
lutheran williams head of the new roads
road school which
amanda gorman attended first and
foremost
you must be so proud well i'm i'm nearly
speechless i mean
it's hard to put into words how proud i
am um of what she's been able to do
it seems a little unfair mr williams
just to call her a poet
because i mean she's clearly a
performance poet
which is a i mean it's a whole different
skill set
yes she is a performance poet i think
that amanda
puts her whole soul in all of her
emotions and conveying
the depths of her poetry and it is
very much her unique artistic creation
that is very individualized i mean it
was a
you know in many respects a very sort of
you don't want to say it in a
patronizing way
but because she is so young it did seem
an incredibly mature piece
well i think it's really interesting you
know amanda attended
new road school from the time she was in
kindergarten and
the school was originally um
founded shortly after the rodney king
riots in 1995
and because the founders looked around
and they said there's not a
socioeconomically and racially
and culturally integrated school in los
angeles 40 years after brown versus the
board of education
so they decided to create this school
where the assumption would be
that all children have unlimited
potential
and that it is the um job of schools to
help them develop their unique gifts
and amanda got that invitation to
really find her voice and to think
deeply
critically and to really
i think have these profound insights
that she
could translate into these exquisite
works of art
did she show that level of potential
then at an earlier age i mean did was
she someone that you looked at
as as the head there and say well you
know we could really see things coming
from this girl
yes i will say that i mean she before
she left
um our school she became the first youth
laureate of los angeles
and then she became the first youth poet
laureate of
the west and then when she went to
harvard she became
the first youthport laureate of the
united states
amanda is incredibly driven and what's
beautiful about amanda is she's driven
to transform the world
is she a sort of very confident young
woman or or will she have been
i always think looking at even when she
stepped up to the podium yesterday i was
sort of had my
my heart in my mouth a little bit for
someone so young thinking
she must be terrified now
well it's interesting because you know
as i said i think one of the things that
you know i credit to some extent um the
school with is
our school gives the students an
invitation to be their authentic selves
and i think because
they are they are taught to be very
comfortable in themselves and they grow
up in an environment at the school
where the foundation is love and respect
and compassion
they really leave us with incredible
confidence and poise
and they are able to walk
their own road and to be unafraid in
many ways of what others think
i didn't think it was very interesting
that she you know she came out with a
piece that was
it reflected on the negative side of of
the last four years
in her view and in her opinion but not
not in an overly sort of
vicious way i mean it was she was very
much wanting to look at the positive
moving forward it really was a message
of hope i thought
yes i i think that's true i mean i think
that amanda's
poetry she offered a critical
well-informed perspective
of what had been happening in the
country
yet she was not cynical
and she gave the country the hope that
it could fulfill its promise
and i think that's very consistent with
the values that she grew up with
are you looking forward mr williams to
inviting her back to the school
to uh to give some sort of recital
well it's interesting amanda is still
very close to the school and amanda the
untold story is that amanda has an
extraordinary mother
and her mother remains in close contact
and amanda also has
a twin sister who is a brilliant
filmmaker who also started in
kindergarten
wow it's quite a family um
she's now turning into a real role model
though isn't she i mean the idea she
said in her own words the
the skinny black girl with a raised by a
single mother
doing what she's doing i mean that that
really does
pitch her as a role model for for
for particularly young black children
who
you know we know there's there's still a
lot of racial tension in the united
states may
look at the future with a more bleak
outlook
well i think that you know one of the
things that it makes me so proud about
amanda is that i think she
was able to attend our school and when
she attended our school she took
advantage of every opportunity
and she was able to really liberate her
potential
and i think amanda is the embodiment of
what's possible
when opportunity meets ambition
mr williams it is a pleasure to talk to
you this morning thank you very much
indeed